[Musique]
partout en france comme ici à rouen ils
manifestent pour réclamer des hausses de
salaires et notamment une augmentation
du smic le mot d'ordre est simple un ces
augmentations des salaires et
augmentation du de création d'emplois il
faut maintenant rendre un peu et rendre
un peu ça veut dire que là où il ya des
marches là où il ya des salaires qui
sont indécents qui sont trop bas qui
sont en dessous du smic dans les
branches professionnelles ils se doivent
de négocier on à la marque les salaires
ce soit la caf qui nous les verts sz
quand il faut aller chercher la prime
d'activité nous ce qu'on veut c'est que
ce soit les employeurs qui verse les
salaires on est baladé à de polémique en
polémique ce sont des démagogues
d'extrême droite qui finalement tiennent
le haut du pavé donc c'est important de
montrer qu'on est présent à mâcon saint
vite dans cette campagne
présidentielle est vrai problème ils se
sont gavés comme jamais et en plus
plutôt que de donner du salaire plutôt
que de donner des primes s'ils veulent
pas donner de salaire ils ont avec cet
agent racheter leurs propres actions
pour en faire monter le cours donc
clairement on a affaire à une classe
parasite
côté là rendez compte on parle des
sujets absolument essentiel puis c'est
aujourd'hui que débute le vote de la
primaire populaire quelque quatre cent
soixante sept mille à personne se sont
inscrits pour participer à cette
consultation citoyenne afin de désigner
leur candidat pour la présidentielle à
gauche ce processus de primaires
populaires qui pouvait être très
sympathique part parce que quand les
citoyens se mêle de démocratie c'est
toujours très important
bah mon père j'espère qu'il sera pas un
présent parce qu' elle ne vivra qu'une
panne pendant toute la soirée
au boulot je l' ai dit à plusieurs
reprises la page est tournée j'ai une
proposition un projet société des
journalistes de france inter appelons-la
pour faire court le comité de salut
public accuse la direction de rendre
marine le pen sympathique
à bas le jour où j'ai explosé à 8 ans où
notre immeuble a explosé on a déposé 20
kg de dynamite devant notre porte et
qu'on s'est retrouvé en pleine nuit
sur un tapis
de verre brisé sans domicile thierry
mariani est ce que vous allez rejoindre
eric zemmour n'ont pas prévu donc c'est
qu'elles soient les sondages quels que
soient les sondages parce que je pense
que la meilleure candidate c'est marine
le pen le cnj radio france demande que
la direction corrige le tir afin de ne
pas tomber dans la complaisance et
l'anecdotique écrit-elle de nombreux
indicateurs sont en hausse le nombre
d'homicides a augmenté de 4% en 2021 les
coups et blessures recensés notamment
dans le contexte familial ont bondi de
12% et escroquerie ont aussi explosé à
cause notamment de la montée de la
cyberdélinquance au fur et à mesure du
temps ça ne donne pas bien trois mois
aux six mois il y as sont collectivement
en abandon d'un certain nombre de
marques de respect à l'égard de ceux qui
détiennent une certaine autorité ou de
ceux qui représentent les français c'est
surtout l'année d'un triste record celui
des violences sexuelles viols agressions
harcèlement 75 1800 fait déclaré l'an
dernier + 33 % par rapport à 2020 ces
derniers mois des dizaines
d'automobilistes ont découvert leur
véhicule retourné sur un flanc comme
vous le voyez sur ces photos un
phénomène d'abord apparue dans le loiret
qui semble gagner le reste de la france
je me suis payé à sous préfet qui
interdisait à la police municipale
d'aller dans certains quartiers en me
disant c'est le raisonnement se disant
tôt tant qu'il faut ça il faut pas pire
la cible des voleurs le pot catalytique
il contient en effet des métaux précieux
tels que le platine le rhodium ou le
palladium qui valent plusieurs disent in
de milliers d'euros le kilo